[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: OK, everybody.
Let's begin.
Welcome back.
Good to see you
all here on Zoom.
So we're going to
pick up with what
we had been
discussing last week,
which was an introduction
to NP-completeness.
So we're following on our
description of time complexity.
We started talking
about the time
complexity classes, the class
P, the nondeterministic classes,
the class NP, P versus
NP problem, and then
leading to this discussion
of NP-completeness.
And today we're going
to prove the big theorem
in the field, which really
kind of got things going back
in the early 1970s
by Cook and Levin
that there was actually
an NP-complete problem,
that SAT in particular is
an NP-complete problem.
And then we'll also talk about
3SAT, which is a useful tool.
Just to remember, we had this
notion of NP-completeness.
A language is NP-complete
if it's in NP.
And everything else in NP
is polynomial time reducible
to it.
And if an NP-complete
problem turns out
to have a polynomial
time solution,
then every NP-problem has
a polynomial time solution.
And that's part of the
importance of NP-completeness,
because since we consider it
unlikely that P equals NP,
and that there probably are
some problems that are an NP,
but are not solvable
in polynomial time.
That would imply that
an NP-complete problem
would have that property.
And so proving a problem
being NP-complete
is evidence, very
strong evidence,
that it doesn't have a
polynomial time solution.
And so therefore it's
called intractable.
It's a very difficult problem.
So the way we are going
to typically show problems
NP-complete is by reducing
a known-- a previously
known NP-complete
problem to that problem.
Often it's 3SAT, as we've seen
in several examples already,
or it could be
some other example.
So let's just survey briefly
the things that we've already--
languages that we've already
seen, which are NP-complete.
So we have the
languages SAT, which
has a direct reduction
from every NP problem.
And so we're going to show
that today, that every NP
language is polynomial time
reducible to SAT, which
is, in turn, reducible to 3SAT.
And we showed
previously that 3SAT
is reducible to
CLIQUE and HAMPATH.
And in recitation,
if you went to that,
they showed that the SUBSET-SUM
problem and the undirected
HAMPATH problems are also
reducible from previously
shown--
well, either from
3SAT, or in the case
of the undirected
HAMPATH problem,
it's reducible from
the HAMPATH problem.
And the conclusion, once we have
these two blue reducibilities
shown, then we know that all of
these problems are NP-complete.
So the class NP
basically breaks down
into the NP-complete
problems, P problems, problems
that are in P, and then
there might be problems
in between as well.
So there are some
problems that are not
known to be in either category.
And in fact, there's
an old theorem
which shows that if P
is different from NP,
then there are
actually problems that
are in the intermediate state.
And of course, it's
possible that P equals NP,
and then everything
collapses down
to be the same with the
tiny exception of the sigma
star and empty set languages,
which can never be complete.
OK.
So that's our quick review.
Here is a check-in
that I'm going
to use to get us ready
for the big proof
that we're going to be
spending most of the lecture
on about showing
SAT is NP-complete,
but just to define a
little notation, which
you might have-- maybe
you've seen already.
But I'm going to do it in
the form of a check-in.
So I'm sure you've
all seen the big sum
notation using a big
sigma to represent a sum
over some set of possibilities.
Just as there is the big
sigma notation, we have--
you can have other
operations that
apply to a set of elements.
So in this case, we're going
to be seeing the big end AND
and the big OR operation--
it's going to--
notation, which is
going to allow us to talk about
taking the AND of many things
or the OR of many
things, because we're
going to be building
these Boolean formulas.
And so ANDs and ORs are going
to be the operations that we're
going to be focusing on.
And so just as an
example just to make sure
we're all understanding
this notation,
if you have two strings x
and y written out in terms
of their individual symbols.
So they're both of length n.
So x is x1 to xn.
Y is y1 to yn.
And now I write the
following expression.
The big AND for i ranging
between 1 and n of xi
equal to yi.
If that big AND is true, what
does it tell us about x and y?
And I'm just going to offer
you two possibilities,
that either x and y agree
on some symbol or are equal,
namely that they
agree on every symbol.
And so let's just pull
that up as a quick poll
to get us going here.
I just want to make sure
you understand the notation
because we're going
to be using that a lot
in describing the polynomial
time reduction from languages
in NP to the SAT language.
OK.
I think most of you
have got the idea.
So let's finish this up quick.
So another 15
seconds, please, just
to give you a chance
to participate.
OK.
We're going to close this poll.
Last chance, last call.
All right.
So yes, the big AND--
as most of you can see, the
big AND says that x1 equals y1,
and x2 equals y2, and x3
equals y3 so they're all--
every symbol in x is equal to
the corresponding symbol in y.
If we had a big OR
instead of a big AND,
then A would be
the correct answer,
because then just there
would be some place where
they agree instead of every
place where they agree.
So let's then start to
launch into this big theorem.
The proof itself is
a mass of details
with one underlying idea.
And in fact, it's an
idea we've seen before.
But let's-- before we
get ahead of ourselves,
let's just understand
what we're trying to do.
So we want to show that this
language SAT is NP-complete.
We remember what SAT is.
It's Boolean formulas
that are satisfiable.
So we already showed that the
SAT prob-- so being NP-complete
means it has these two features.
It's in NP, and everything
in NP is reducible to it.
So first of all, SAT is in
NP, as we've already seen.
The witness that shows
the formula is satisfiable
is simply the
satisfying assignment
that evaluates to true.
So now we're going to pick
some language in NP, A,
and show that A is polynomial
time reducible to SAT.
So this is going to apply
to any language A in NP.
So let A be some language in NP.
It's decided by some
nondeterministic Turing machine
M in time n to the k.
That's what it
means to be an NP.
I'm going to be ignoring
the constant factors when
we could carry that
throughout the proof.
It just would make
the description
a little more
cumbersome and wouldn't
change any of the ideas.
So let's just say it's M
runs in time n to the k,
and recognizes or decides
this language in A.
So it's a
nondeterministic machine.
So we've got to give
a polynomial time
reduction from A to SAT.
That's what I have to
demonstrate to you.
So what does that
reduction look like?
It's going to map strings,
which may or may not
be in A, to formulas, which
may or may not be satisfied.
That's what the
reduction has got to do.
So saying that out
more formally is it's
going to take some
string w and map it
to a formula we'll
call phi sub M, w,
where M is the machine that
decides A and w is the input.
So f is going to map w
to this formula, where
the string is in the language
exactly when the formula is
satisfied.
And the formula is going
to depend upon M and w.
That's why it just has--
it's written in this way.
So we've seen that
kind of thing before.
So basically, my job--
we have this language
A that's in NP.
And now we have some string
w, which might be in A,
or maybe not is in A. And I have
to quickly in polynomial time
now produce a formula which is
going to be satisfiable exactly
when the string w is in A.
So how is that
formula going to work?
How can I produce
such a formula?
Which I mean, of course, I don't
know whether w is in A or not,
because I'm just the
polynomial time reduction.
And A is an NP language.
So polynomial time
probably is not
enough to solve
whether w is in A.
So I've got to do that mapping
without knowing the answer.
And the idea is that--
and this is where we've seen
things like this before--
the formula we're
going to construct
simulates the machine on w.
So in some way it's going
to do that simulation.
The trick is figuring out
how to-- what that means.
But the interpretation
of that formula
is that in a sense describes,
says, in my informal language,
that M accepts w.
Very much like-- there's a lot
of parallel here between this
construction and, for
example, the construction,
the PCP construction,
where we made an instant--
given a machine and
an input, we made
a set of those dominoes,
where finding a match
forced you to
simulate the machine.
Here finding a
satisfying assignment
is going to force you
to simulate the machine.
So the satisfying
assignment is going
to be a computation
history for M on w.
And I'm just going to
write that computation
history in a particular way.
So it's going to have a somewhat
different encoding, which
is going to help us to visualize
what's going on better.
So that's the approach.
That's the basic idea
of what we're trying
to-- what we're going to do.
So I'm happy to take
a minute if you have
any questions about this part.
But otherwise, I'll
just move on to start
doing the actual construction
of what the formula looks like.
How is it going to do that?
How is that formula
going to work?
OK.
So no questions.
Hopefully, we are all together.
So first of all, let me
describe what my computation
history is going to look like.
And the situation
is a little bit
different than what we
had before because when
we were talking about the
Post correspondence problem
we had a deterministic machine.
And now our machine
is nondeterministic.
So we're going to
call the object--
instead of an accepting
computation or a computation
history, we're just
going to-- we're
going to call it a tableau, or
sometimes an accepting tableau
if you want to emphasize
the accepting nature of it.
But generally, we're just
going to call it a tableau.
So a tableau is really an
accepting computation history
for the machine on
an accepting branch
of its nondeterministic
computation.
So if M accepts w, it's got
to have some accepting branch,
and the tableau is going to be
the sequence of configurations
that the machine goes through
on that accepting branch.
If there are several
accepting branches,
there may be several tableaus.
There will be several tableaus.
So there's going
to be one tableau
for each accepting branch of
the machine's computation on w.
If the machine does not accept
w, there won't be any tableaus.
And so the whole
point is that we're
going to make our formula
represent the statement
that there is a tableau.
And satisfying that
formula is going
to correspond to filling out the
symbols in the tableau to make
it a tableau.
So here is a tableau.
So a tableau is just, again, an
accepting computation history
on some branch, some accepting
branch of the machine's
computation.
The rows are the--
instead of writing the
computation history
out linearly, we're going to
represent it in a table form
where each configuration is
going to be on a separate row.
Now, the dimensions
of that table
are going to be n to
the k by n to the k,
because the machine runs
for n to the k steps.
So there's going to-- if
there's an accepting branch,
it's going to accept within
that number of steps.
And we'll have enough
rows here to write down
all of the configurations that
the machine goes through one
after the next, row by
row, each one having
a configuration in it.
And then at the bottom,
there'll be an accept.
Minor detail, if the
machine accepts earlier,
we'll just say the
machine stays in the--
once it enters an
accept, the machine
does not change
from that point on.
So the rule of the machine
is nothing changes.
And it just remains in the same
configuration from that point
on.
So important to understand what
we're-- if you're not following
what I mean by a tableau,
you're doomed for this lecture.
So it makes sense for
you to ask a question
to understand what
we mean by tableau.
So just a few more
elements here.
So this is going to be the
start configuration for M on w.
This would be an
accepting configuration
here down at the very last row.
And you might imagine--
I think I've filled out
some hypothetical first step
of the machine after the start
where maybe the machine was--
when it's in-- remember how
we encoded our configurations.
So this is the machine
is in state q0,
looking at the w, the first
symbol of the input, w1.
And maybe when it's in q0
looking at that first symbol,
it moves to state q7,
and goes right, and then
changes that w1 to an A. And
so now here is the head shown
moved one position to the
right in the new state q7.
I mean, of course,
that depends on what
the machine is designed to do,
what the transition function
is.
But this possibly
is what happens.
So does the--
OK, so good.
Does the tableau trace
all steps of all branches?
No.
The tableau corresponds
to one accepting branch.
Each different
accepting branch is
going to have its own tableau.
So there might be several
different ways of filling out
that second row even.
Of course, the first row is
going to be-- in any tableau,
it's got to be the same.
Once I know w--
here I've written down--
maybe I should
unpack this for you.
It's in the start state here,
then here are the first--
here are n symbols of
w, w's of length n.
So there's w1, w2, up to wn.
And then I'm padding out
the rest with blanks.
So I should have said that, too.
But OK.
So I want to make my table
n to the k by n to the k
because that's going to
be enough to represent
the entire--
all of these configurations of
M running for most n to the k
steps, because the machine,
even if it sends its head
moving to the right as
fast as it possibly can,
it's never going to have--
it's never going to
go outside this box
if it only runs for
n to the k steps.
So this is going
to be big enough
to represent the entire
computation of M.
So it means running
for n to the k time.
And the input w is of length n.
All right.
What is k?
So k is the running
time of the machine.
So we assumed from the previous
slide that M runs in time n
to the k.
OK.
So a good question here.
How can the tableau
be a square table
if we have a low number
of computation histories,
but a lot of tape?
Well, the low number computation
history, that's a problem.
You're not saying that well.
You know, each
computation history
is in a different table.
So this, I'm representing a
single computation history
here.
There may be-- there are going
to be many configurations.
So I can't have a small
number of configurations
using a lot of tape,
because I can only
use one more cell, one
additional tape cell each time
I--
each additional
step of the machine.
Yeah.
So there's really no
difference between this.
If you want to think of this
as a computation history,
that's fine.
This is really just the
standard terminology
that's used when you're proving
this particular theorem.
Typically people talk
about it as a tableau,
but it's really just
a computation history.
The q state--
I mean, the question about
what are these states' q,
this is the way we
represent configurations.
So this means the
machine is in a state.
They're not all going
down the diagonal.
The states are going to zigzag
here through this picture
here, depending upon how the
head of the machine moves.
So you have to go
back and review
how we represent the
configurations of the machine.
Remember the configuration
is a snapshot of the machine
at a given point.
How do we know that M
runs in polynomial time?
We're assuming M
runs in polynomial.
We started off with a
language that's in NP.
So it's a nondeterministic
polynomial time machine,
and we're picking one
branch that accepts
and writing down all the
sequence of configurations
the machine goes through.
Let's move on.
And maybe ask more questions
as they come to you,
and I'll pick out some
to answer if that's
going to be helpful to others.
So we're going to now
construct this formula
to say that M accepts w.
Again, that was what we--
that's our goal.
And it says that a
tableau for M on w exists.
And basically what
that means is we
want to say that it starts
right, it ends right,
and everything in
between is right,
and then we're going to need
some other stuff to talk
about how we're going to be
encoding those symbols using
Boolean variables.
So those are going
to be the four parts.
Here's the start.
It starts right.
Here it ends right.
Here it moves right.
And here it talks about
the encoding of the symbols
into Boolean variables.
So those are the four
parts of this formula
that I'm going to describe.
I hope you got your
question answered
as to why the total number
of columns is n to the k,
because it's just big
enough to fit the entire--
all configurations
that the machine
is running for at
most n to the k
steps, which is
what we're assuming.
OK.
So now just getting
back to that,
I'm going to describe these
different components now
on separate slides.
Let me start out with this
component phi cell, which
is sort of the most
fundamental one
because it talks
about how we're going
to be encoding those symbols
of the tableau into the Boolean
variables.
So again, here's kind of the
picture to have in mind of this
tableau, this n to the
k by n to the k table,
representing some accepting
branch of the machine's
computation if there is one.
And so now let me draw
one of the cells here.
I'm going to magnify it.
So this is the i, j cell here.
And I'm going to--
there are going
to be a collection
of Boolean variables associated
with each one of the cells.
So each one of
the cells is going
to have a bunch of
variables all to itself.
And those are going to be
basically indicator variables.
They're going to
indicate which symbol
that cell gets to have in it.
So again, picture here--
in this tableau,
we don't know how
it's going to get filled out.
But however it gets filled
out, each one of these cells
gets some symbol.
And that symbol could
either be a tape alphabet
symbol, or a symbol
representing a state.
That's the way we do
our configurations.
So it could be a
tape alphabet symbol
here showing the magnification.
Maybe it's the tape
alphabet symbol, which
represents the blank symbol.
Or maybe it's
represents some state.
Now, how am I going to
encode that with variables?
So this-- let me--
this is the collection
of variables
that's going to apply to the
entire formula phi sub M, w.
Each cell is-- so
each cell i, j is
going to have a
set of variables,
one for each
possible symbol sigma
that's in the configuration
alphabet, namely a tape
symbol or a state symbol.
So I'm going to have--
well, maybe this will become
clear as I'm writing it.
So if I turn the variable x
i, j, sigma equal to true,
that's just a way of saying
that cell i, j contains a sigma.
So if I have x i, j, a, that
means the symbol contains an a.
So I'm going to illustrate
that now for you.
So imagine you have
lights representing all
the different x i, j's
for the different sigmas.
Didn't say that well.
So we're in cell i, j.
So these are all
x i, j variables.
They're all x i,
j sigma variables
for the different sigmas
that can go in this cell.
So all different
possible sigmas.
So this is gamma union Q.
So now if I have an A
here in that cell, so then
the variable x i, j, a is true.
And just helping
you visualize that,
that's going to correspond
to turning the light on.
There's going to be
a light associated
with each one of
these variables.
And it's going to be turned
on when that variable is true.
Similarly, if I have
the blank symbol
is the thing that
goes in that cell,
then that variable
gets turned on.
I hope you can see it.
Maybe it's a little bit
small on your screen.
The x i, j blank,
a variable is true.
And similarly, if it's q7 here,
the x i, j q7 variable is true.
So that's the way we're
going to be encoding
the contents of these
cells using these indicator
variables.
And now we have to start making
some Boolean logic to make sure
that those variables reasonably
represent the cell con--
the contents of these cells.
So for example, what
would be the first thing
that comes to your mind?
Well, we better not
have two lights going on
in any one of the
cells, because then we
have two symbols in that cell.
And that's not allowed.
Each cell is going-- we want
each cell to have exactly one
symbol.
And that corresponds
to each cell having
exactly one of its
lights turned on,
or equivalently,
each cell should
have exactly one of
the variables be true.
That's the very first
part of the formula
is just going to say that.
So let me show you
what that looks like.
So here we're talking
about this phi cell.
It says that there's exactly
one light on per cell,
or in other words,
exactly one of the x i,
j sigmas is true for each i, j.
So this is how I'm going
to actually express
that using my Boolean formula.
I'm sort of color coding
the different parts
of the formula, which I'm
writing out to you here
in English.
So first, I want to say this.
So in every cell, there's at
least one light that's on,
and there's at most
one light that's on.
So here's the green part.
This is going to say at
least one light is on.
So I'm going to say that
by taking all of the var--
all of the symbols that
can appear in that cell,
and taking an OR over all of
those different associated
variables.
So it's either got
the first symbol on,
or the second symbol is
there, or dot dot dot,
or the last symbol is there.
One of those has
got to be there.
I'm going to write this
using my big OR notation.
So for sigma appearing in
this set of possibilities,
one of those variables
has got to be on at least.
That's what this
big OR tells you.
Now we want to make sure that
there's at most one that's on.
So that there are not--
there's at least one on, but
there are not two that are on.
So I'm going to have an
additional part of the formula
here, which says--
and I hope you can read this.
It's a little small.
If I have two different
symbols, sigma and tau,
that are configuration--
possible configuration symbols,
where sigma and tau are not
equal.
So that's I'm
reading it out to you
if it's too small
for your screen.
Then I'm going to say
it's not possible.
So I have the negation of x
i, j sigma, and x i, j tau.
So saying it another
way, it's not the case
that that cell contains both
sigma and tau for any two
symbols sigma and tau as
long as they're different.
And we want to take these two
formulas and add them together.
And this tells me
in the cell i, j,
there's exactly one of
the variables is true.
Exactly one of the lights is on.
And that's going
to represent which
symbol goes into that cell.
And then I want to take the
AND over all possible cells
to make sure that I'm going
to now apply that everywhere.
And so now I do an AND for i
and j ranging between 1 and n
to the k to apply this logic
throughout the picture.
Yeah.
Sigma unions--
asking sigma union Q
contains the input, output, yes.
This is not a sigma.
This is a gamma.
Gamma is the tape alphabet.
This is any symbol, including
an input symbol, from sigma
is going to be in gamma.
So this is any symbol
can appear on the tape.
And this expression here, that
is the expression phi sub cell.
So here's a little
check-in for you.
But maybe before we
jump into the check-in,
let's just make sure--
it may be better to
take some questions,
and then we can ask
the check-in for you.
Do you understand?
I mean, if you're
not getting this,
you should try to figure
out how to get it,
because this is really
just the foundation.
It only gets more--
it is not a very
complicated proof
once you sort of get the
idea of what's going on,
but if you're not
getting this part,
you won't be able
to get the rest.
OK.
I have no idea what the--
what that means, but I'll
read it out to you guys.
This looks like a one-hot tensor
encoding, same from common--
same form commonly used in ML.
OK.
It's just an indicate--
I would just call them
indicator variables.
Why is it sigma union
Q for the big AND here?
Sigma union Q?
You mean gamma union Q?
[GASPING]
This is wrong.
OK.
Now I understand why
everybody is upset.
This should be a
gamma, not a sigma.
There's a boo-boo.
Sorry about that.
I don't know if I can
fix that without breaking
the whole slide, so I'm
not going to even try.
This symbol here should
be gamma, not sigma.
It's a typo.
Thanks for catching that.
Yes.
So the question is--
OK.
So phi sub cell is just
trying to make sure
that the encoding represents
setting a bunch of symbols
into the tableau.
Not-- so each cell is
going to have one symbol
exactly, not two, not zero.
So that's what phi sub--
if you've satisfied, if
you've set the variables
to satisfy phi sub
cell, then there's
going to be one
symbol on in each--
one symbol in each
of those cells.
Now, another question,
this is not a CNF.
No, this is not a CNF.
That's the second half
of-- that's going to be--
I hope we don't run out of time.
But I have a way of converting
general SAT formulas to CNFs
and preserving satisfiability.
So we're going to do
that reduction afterward.
Here's a little check
to see if you understand
at some level what's going on.
How many variables does
this formula actually have?
Is order n?
Order n square?
n to the k?
Remember, k is the running
time of the machine.
Or n to the 2k?
What do you think?
So I mean, for how
many variables.
I mean that in all of
phi sub M. How many
variables do we have all
together in this formula
if that's what the question is.
And here are the variables.
So describing them
here-- x i, j, sigma.
OK.
I'm going to close this.
So pick something.
All right.
Ending polling, 1, 2, 3.
OK.
Yeah.
That's a good question.
So first of all,
the correct answer
is, in fact, D. It's
order n to the 2k.
Now, I'm getting
some questions about,
what about the size
of gamma and Q?
Well, those are
going to be fixed.
They depend only on the machine,
but they don't depend on n.
So thinking about it
functionally in terms of n,
that's going to be a
constant multiplier.
And so it's going to be
absorbed within the big O.
So that's why we have--
these are constant
relative to n.
These are fixed.
There are not n to the
k possible symbols.
There's a fixed
number of symbols.
It depends only on the machine.
So we're looking at
a particular machine,
and what happens when
you look at large inputs.
So why is D and not C?
Well, don't forget--
how big is this table?
This is n to the
k by n to the k.
So there are n to the 2k cells,
n to the k quantity squared,
or n to the 2k cells here.
And so there's a
collection of variables
for each cell, some fixed number
of variables for each cell.
So that's why its
order n to the 2k.
Good.
So let's move on.
I think we're
actually-- hold on.
So we have one more
slide, and I think
then we have a break after.
So now let's next talk about
constructing two more pieces
of the phi sub M, w formula.
So we already got
phi sub cell done.
Let's look at phi sub
start and phi sub accept.
And phi start is
going to tell us
that the start configuration
has exactly these symbols.
And phi accept tells us that the
bottom configuration contains
an accepting state somewhere.
So how are we going
to write that down?
Well, first of all, I'm going
to write these down just cell
by cell.
So first of all, phi start
is going to say the cell 1,
1 contains a q0.
I mean, I know what the
start configuration should
be, because thinking of me, or
think of us as the reduction,
the reduction is
given M. It's given w.
So it knows what
the start state is.
It knows what the
symbols of w are.
So it knows what that
start configuration is.
It's just q0 followed
by the n symbols
of w followed by blanks.
So it wants the very first
cell in the left-hand corner
here to be a q0, the start state
of the machine, which it knows.
So it's going to say x sub 1,
1, q0, that has to be turned on.
So it's going to be AND of
a bunch of variables here.
And in order to satisfy phi sub
start, all of those variables
have to be set to true.
So that means we have to
have a q0 in that cell.
So now we're going to
do the next cell here.
The 1, 2, the next cell of
the start configuration.
So phi start is
going to have x 1, 2.
So that's the next place.
It contains w1.
And so on.
x 1, 3 contains w2,
all the way up to wn,
and then there's going to be
a bunch of additional parts
which say that we have
blanks in the rest,
just spelling out exactly all
of the symbols in that top row.
Because that's what
the phi start formula,
or sub formula of
the overall formula
we're making looks like.
Now let's take a
look at phi accept.
Phi accept, because
I'm just looking
for q accept to appear
somewhere in that bottom row,
I'm going to do that
in terms of an OR.
So here is-- the variables
now, notice, have n to the k
because it's the last
row in the table.
So row n to the k here.
And then I'm going to vary
j from 1 to n to the k.
So j, the column
number, is going
to range from 1 to n to the k.
And I'm looking
for that to accept.
So x n to the k j, where
j's vary, and q accept.
One of those has to be true.
One of those has
to be turned on.
And so that's why it's a big OR.
And that's my phi accept piece.
And now we'll take
a little break.
And feel free to ask
me some more questions.
Let me just start our clock.
Go grab yourself some coffee,
or ask me some questions.
I'm happy to answer them.
Why don't we check that q
accept only appears once?
Is it possible for q
accept to appear twice?
That's a great question.
So that would definitely
be a broken configuration
if that happened,
because a configuration
can have-- must have exactly
one state symbol appearing.
The way we're going to enforce
that is with the phi move
part of the formula,
which we haven't seen yet.
So phi move is
going to guarantee
that the machine is
acting correctly,
so that all of the
rows of the tableau
are all legal configurations,
and they all legally follow
from the previous.
So really, in a sense,
the hard-- heavy lifting
is coming in phi move, but
it's really not that bad.
Somebody says, out of
curiosity, how close
is this intuition proof
to the actual proof?
This is the actual proof.
There's no-- I'm
not hiding anything.
I mean, we're being
a little loose here,
but you can turn this--
we're not cutting
any corners here.
This is exactly
how the proof goes.
And so not-- you're
getting the real deal here.
Somebody wanted to see the
previous slide, so here we are.
Whoops.
Is there something
you want to ask?
So phi cell says there's
exactly one symbol per cell.
And the variables are set in
a way in terms of thinking
of them as indicator variables.
There's exactly one variable
set to true in each cell.
So there's exactly
one symbol per cell.
That's what phi cell tells you.
If you don't have that,
then you have a mess.
So you've got to
start with that.
And then with the--
other things are
going to be
additional conditions,
which when satisfied are
going to enforce the rest
of the properties that we want.
Why would the proof fail if
we replace n to the k with 2
to the n to the k?
So OK.
I presume where does-- we'll
just use the polynomial running
time of the machine of M,
the nondeterministic machine.
I mean, if you had
an enormous tab--
we have to show ultimately
that this reduction is
a polynomial time reduction.
And that's going to depend
on how big the tableau is,
because that's going to tell
us how big the formula we're
producing is, phi sub M, w.
If phi sub M, w is
exponentially big,
we don't have a prayer of being
able to output that formula
in polynomial time.
If there were less
than n to the k steps,
do we repeat the
last configuration?
Yeah, that's what I said.
If the machine ends early,
the last configuration
just stays there.
So we're going to modify the
definition of the machine
slightly so it just stays.
Yeah.
OK.
Let me not take
the other-- there's
a bunch of other
questions, some of them
a little on the technical side.
Let me-- maybe I'll
try to address them
as they come along if it
turns out to work to do that.
So the break is over.
Why don't we-- is it possible
that the encoding configuration
will not fit in n to the k?
So the question is,
is there a possibility
that the encoding
of the configuration
won't fit in n to the k?
If the machine runs
for n to the k steps,
the configuration has to
fit within n to the k,
because it can't use anything
more within n to the k steps.
So think about it.
But no.
The answer is the
configurations--
if the machine runs
in time n to the k,
that whole tableau is
big enough to write down
the entire computation history.
All right, so let's continue.
Phi sub move, this
is, in a sense,
the part which is going
to tell us that we
started right, we ended right.
Phi cell says every cell
contains one symbol.
And now we have to say that
the whole interior is correct.
How are we going to do that?
So these are the parts
we've already done.
And the way I'm
going to describe
that is in terms of these
kind of little windows
I'm calling neighborhoods.
So imagine here we have a 2 by
3 rectangle, which I'm going
to call a 2 by 3 neighborhood.
And what I'm going to argue,
but I'm not going to prove here.
I'm just going to
really state it,
but it's really just a sort
of more or less obvious fact.
But the proof-- the book has
the formal proof, that if any--
every one of these
here is legitimate,
is legal according to
the rules of the machine,
if every single--
imagine you have these--
oops.
Let me put myself back on
here so you can see me.
If you have here
every 2 by 3 window,
you can take this
as a window, and you
slide that over the entire
picture of the tableau.
And everything here
looks OK as far
as the running of the machine.
So I'll say what that
means in a second.
But if everything looks
locally fine everywhere,
then the whole tableau
has to be a valid tableau
in terms of the rules of M.
Maybe it's easier
if I describe what
I mean by these being legal.
So these neighborhoods,
these 2 by 3 neighborhoods
are legal if they're consistent
with M's transition function.
So I'm going to
describe rather than--
I mean, to do this
formally, I would
have to go through a
process that we went--
like what we did when we
went through the construction
for the Post
correspondence problem,
and say if the machine moves
left, this thing happens.
If it moves right, that's--
I think that it's
not really necessary.
You can kind of get
the idea very clearly
by doing it at a little
bit of a higher level.
So let's look at what I mean
by a legal neighborhood.
So a legal neighborhood is
a setting of the values,
the six values of this
2 by 3 neighborhood,
in a way which doesn't
violate M's rules.
So for example, if M, when
it's in state q7 reading of b,
goes into state
q3 and moves left,
then this would be a legal
neighborhood, because it
shows the head moving
left, the b becoming a c.
So reading a b,
I should also say
that it converts that b to a c.
And we just head
left into state q3.
So this would be a
legal neighborhood
if that's the way--
so being legal depends upon
the transition function
of the machine.
So given the
transition function,
that's going to tell you which
are the legal neighborhoods.
So another legal neighborhood--
this would always
be a legal neighborhood--
is that if nothing changes.
So that means the head of the
machine was somewhere else.
And so whatever was on
the tape in this step
is going to be the same stuff
in those places one step later.
Here's another possible
legal neighborhood.
If the head suddenly
appears on one of the cells
either in the left
or the right, that
would correspond to the machine
moving its head from somewhere
off the neighborhood into the
neighborhood in that step.
So this could be a
legal neighborhood,
provided the machine
actually does
move its head left
into a state q5
at some point under
some conditions.
And here is another kind of
a weird legal neighborhood.
If you have a, b, c, and
then the a changes to a d,
that could also be
a legal neighborhood
if the machine transition
function allows
an a to get converted
to a d when there
is some machine-- when there
is some state reading that a,
and that state also
moves its head left.
So it doesn't move
into this picture.
So those are examples
of legal neighborhoods.
Let me show you some
illegal neighborhoods.
Just I'm doing this-- this is
kind of a proof by example now.
This is perhaps the
most intuitive part.
But I claim that this is easy
to turn this into something
airtight and formal.
So this would be
clearly illegal.
If you have a piece of the
tape in the previous step where
it's a, b, c, and then
suddenly the b changes to a d.
The symbol on the tape
changes out of nowhere
without having a head
nearby to a different--
to something else.
That could never happen.
So that would be illegal.
Another thing that
would be illegal
is if a state
appears from nowhere.
That could never happen.
Or if it just disappears.
And here's another--
here's an interesting one.
If a state becomes two states.
Don't forget the machine
is nondeterministic.
So the machine in
principle could
move its head left on one
branch and move its head right
on a different branch,
but those would have
to be in different tableaus.
They can't be in
the same tableau,
because that doesn't
correspond to any
of the threads of the
computation, those
with multiple threads.
And I say this because if you
think about my claim, which
is going to put down over
here, that if every 2
by 3 neighborhood is legal, then
the tableau overall corresponds
to a computation history.
This illustrates why it's
not enough to have a 2
by 2 neighborhood, where
you really need the 2 by 3.
Because if this was a
2 by 2 neighborhood,
if you just look at these four--
this leftmost 2 by 2, that could
be a legal neighborhood if it
was a 2 by 2, if the rules of
the machine allowed for that.
And the right four box--
right four cells could also
be a legal neighborhood.
So you could have
something that looks
OK from the perspective
of 2 by 2 neighborhoods,
but globally, in terms
of the overall tableau,
it's completely nonsensical
because it has multiple hits.
But if you have a 2
by 3 neighborhood,
it's big enough to prevent
this situation from occurring.
And then you can
check the details.
And I think it's very
plausible that it guarantees
that the overall
tableau is legitimate
if all of the 2 by 3
neighborhoods are legal.
And so that's what we're
going to turn into a Boolean
expression.
We're going to say for
each cell that the set--
for each neighborhood-- so
here's a neighborhood at the i,
j location.
I'm calling this
position here sort
of the home location
for that neighborhood.
For each neighborhood,
it has to be set to one
of the legal possibilities.
And there's, again, only
a fixed number of those
because there's a fixed
number of possible symbols
that can appear in those cells.
So this is that fixed number
to the sixth power at most.
And I'm going to say that
the cell in the upper left,
which would be
this one, is in r.
And this one here is an s.
And this one is a t.
And this one is a v, if
you just trace down what
the indices are telling you.
It says that that piece of the
tape, that piece of the tableau
here is set according to one
of the possible legal settings.
And we're just going to OR over
all of those possible fixed
number of legal settings.
And then I take an AND over
all possible tape cells,
over all possible neighborhoods.
And so that's going
to be my phi move.
And that's it.
OK.
Let's see.
Can I explain again the
third example of illegal?
So this one over here, I
presume, I'm being asked about.
Well, if the machine is
in a state q7 reading a c,
the head has to move
either left or right.
So at the next
configuration, there's
got to be a state symbol
appearing either in this cell
or in this cell.
And here the tape--
the head has basically
just vanished with nowhere
to-- it's gone.
That could not happen
according to the rules
of the machine the way we
talk about Turing machines.
So that's not possible.
So this would be an
illegal neighborhood.
You want to prevent
any of the bad stuff
from happening anywhere in here.
So only good stuff can
be happening locally.
And that guarantees the
overall picture is OK.
Do we have to check
that the head doesn't
leave the tableau from the
left most to right right?
Yeah, there are some little
details here like that.
So the question is, do I
have to make sure that the--
yeah, you probably need to mark.
I think the book probably
does this correctly.
You may have to mark
the left and right ends
to make sure that--
I mean, the right
end is not a problem,
because the machine can
never go off the right end.
And if you design the
machine so that it never
moves its head off the left
end either, which you can do,
then you wouldn't have to
worry about that possibility.
But otherwise, you would have to
put some sort of delimiter here
to enforce the head not
moving off the left end.
So there are some
details like that, too.
There will be two
heads in the same row.
No, this can-- I don't know
what you-- somebody says,
there will be two
heads in the same row.
Please elaborate, because
this is designed not to allow
two heads in the same row.
Could I go over the
OR for legal again?
OK.
The OR, the big OR here, what
I have in mind is I take--
there's going to be-- first
of all, I look at the machine
and I look at the
transition function.
And based on that, I write down
the list of all the legal 2
by 3 neighborhoods.
So all the settings which
correspond to legal 2
by 3 neighborhoods.
There's going to be some
fixed number of those.
100.
There's 100 possible legal
neighborhoods of which
I've written down here four.
But maybe there's
some number, say 100.
So now there's going to
be an OR over those 100
different possibilities.
It's either going to be
this legal neighborhood,
or some other
legal neighborhood,
legal neighborhood.
And for each one of those
legal neighborhoods,
I'm going to say, well, the
variables are set according
to that legal neighborhood, or
the variables are set according
to the next legal neighborhood,
or the variables are
set according to the
next legal neighborhood,
and do that 100 times.
One of those has got to end up--
I mean it's an OR, so
one of them has to work.
Otherwise, the formula fails.
And it will be
false, because you're
going to AND that over
all of the neighborhoods
in the picture.
Is it possible to have
a head on the far left
of the configuration and
one on the far right?
You mean a head over here
and a head over there?
I mean, how'd the
head get there?
It can't happen.
You know, the head has to
come from a head above it.
If you're going to be
worrying about the details
of the boundaries here,
all that's fixable.
So let's not lose
sight of the main idea.
I mean, if you
understand the main idea,
you can fix the little details.
So I want to make sure you
understand the main idea
of what's happening.
So let's finish up this proof.
So in summary, we gave a
reduction from 8 to SAT.
This is what we needed.
It was in those four pieces.
And you really
just need to argue
that that formula we're
building is not too big.
And it's going to be basically
the size of the tableau
if you look at what
we constructed.
The number of variables
is roughly the size
of the tableau.
And the amount of logic that
we're putting into the formula
is also going to
be a fixed amount
of logic independent
of n for each
of the variables
in that tableau.
And somebody asked me about the
size-- how big the indices are.
The indices for the x i
value, the i and j values,
technically, they're going
to be numbers between 1
and n to the k.
So you're going to have
to write those down.
And so that's going to be a
slight additional logarithmic
cost to write those things down.
It's not really that
interesting a point.
And so the overall
f is going to be
computable in polynomial time
because the output is not
very big.
And it's also not complicated
to write the output down.
So that's the end of the proof.
I can take a couple
of questions.
Why can't we just check
that the whole-- this
is a good question.
Why can't we just check
that the whole row is legal?
You can check that a row
actually is a configuration.
But to check that the row
follows from the previous row,
ultimately, the operation
of a Turing machine
is a local thing.
I mean, the way it moves from
one configuration to the next
depends locally on
how where the head is.
And so really, that's
just another way of--
the way I'm saying it
is just really checking
the whole configuration,
but just doing it locally.
I don't know if that's
satisfying to you.
Why don't I move
on because I just
want to make sure
we have enough time
to get to the very last
part, which is a little bit--
I'm afraid, a little technical.
So we're going to kind of
shift gears now and talk
about reducing SAT to 3SAT.
And let's see how it goes.
I don't always have
the most success
with presenting
this little piece,
because it's slightly
a technical argument.
But if you don't
get it, don't worry.
Just you have to
accept that it's true.
But I'd like to
show it to you just
to make the whole presentation
complete in that sense.
So I'm going to give a reduction
that maps general formulas
to 3CNF formulas.
So that's how we
map SAT to 3SAT.
If you remember 3SAT
is satisfiability
but for three CNFs.
So a conjunctive normal form
in the form of those clauses,
which are ANDed together.
And each clause is an OR of a
bunch of literals, which are
variables or negated variables.
So I want to convert phi to phi
prime, which is 3CNF formula,
but preserve the satisfiability.
And phi prime is not going to
be logically equivalent to phi,
because I could do that, too.
I can convert any formula to
a logically equivalent CNF
formula.
Maybe not even a
3CNF, but yeah, you
won't be able to get a
3CNF, but you can get a CNF.
But it might be
exponentially larger.
And that's not good enough.
I have to do the reduction
in polynomial time.
So I can't generate
a much larger formula
that's exponentially larger.
And so I'm going to do that by
adding additional variables.
So it won't be
logically equivalent
because the new formula
is going to have
additional variables in it.
I'm going to kind
of do it by example.
And we'll see how that goes.
So here's phi, which
is not in 3CNF.
It's not even in
CNF, because it's
got ORs of ANDs
appearing, which is not
allowed to happen in a CNF.
So how are we going
to convert that
into a 3CNF formula
preserving the satisfiability?
And just working it
through with this example,
I hope to at least give
you some idea of how you
do the conversion in general.
So first of all, I'm going
to represent this formula
as a tree using its
natural tree structure.
So you understand.
So a AND B becomes a
AND b written as a tree.
And then I OR that with c.
So I get the tree structure
here in sort of the natural way.
And I'm going to label all of
these intermediate nodes, which
are associated now
with operations.
And I'm assuming also that the
formula is fully parenthesized
so that each operation
I'm only thinking about
is applying just the two--
it's a binary operation.
And let's ignore negations for
the minute, because negations,
you can always push those
through down to the leaves.
But it's just going to
make it too complicated.
So negations turn out
not to be a problem.
So there's only
going to be negations
at the level of the
inputs, not at the negation
operations in the middle.
So we have this
tree structure here.
And now I'm going to use
these two logical facts.
And I don't know if--
you've probably all seen
ANDs and ORs, I hope.
Otherwise, it's going
to be really tough.
But there's also other
logical operators,
such as the
implication operator,
where you have A implies B
sort of as a logical operation.
And so this requires that if
A is true, then B is true.
However, if A is false,
B can be anything.
And similarly if B is
true, A can be anything.
The only thing that's
prohibited is that if A is true
and B is false.
That's the only thing
that would be invalid.
And so if you think
about it, that's
going to be equivalent to
saying that either A is false
or B is true.
One of those has to be.
And that's going to be
logically equivalent to saying
that A implies B.
Another logical equivalence
may be more familiar to you.
It's just simply
De Morgan's law,
which says that if you have
the not of A AND B, that's
equivalent to saying the
not of A or the not of B.
I'm going to make
use of both of these.
Now, here, I want to--
I ran out of room on this slide.
So I'm going to take myself
out of the picture here
for a minute.
I had no place else to put this.
So here we have--
if you're going to
think of the AND
in terms of its truth
table, so here's a and b
in terms of a and b.
So 1 and 1 is 1, but all
other settings of a and b
yield 0 for the AND.
And I'm going to
represent those--
if you imagine a and b
is going to be called c.
I'm going to represent
this information
with four small formulas, which
taken together, you AND them
together, are going to force
c to have the correct behavior
associated with a AND b.
So if a AND b are
both 1, then c is 1.
If a is 0 and b is 1,
then it forces c to be 0.
And similarly, every other
setting besides a AND
b being true, for C to
be false, which is what
you want when you have AND.
So I'm going to write
this expression here down
with z1 being in the place of
c by just taking those four
expressions and
ANDing them together.
So this is exactly those same
four expressions written out
linearly.
Now I want to do the
same thing for z2,
but now that's written
in terms of an OR.
So there's a slightly
different truth table
here up in this corner.
So now if either one is
1, we get a 1 result.
And so now if a AND b are
true, you get c is true.
However, if a is
true and b is false,
that still implies c is true.
So I'm going to write down
those rules for specifying
how z2 must be set.
And each one of
these things is going
to get converted into clauses,
three clauses with three
literals, using these
rules over here.
So I'm going to do
that for each zi.
And lastly, to make sure the
whole thing is satisfied,
which means there's
an output of one here,
I'm going to have one
clause associated, which
says that z4, the output, is 1.
Now, I can convert all of those
when I have a AND b implies c.
That's logically equivalent
to not a OR not b OR c.
And the way you can
see that is really
by repeated application
of these rules here.
We're running a
little low on time.
So maybe you'll just have
to check this offline.
But quickly, a AND b implies
c using the first equivalence
is the not of this
part, OR C. And then
I can use De Morgan to
convert that not of an AND
to an OR of the nots.
And then I can remove
the parentheses
because OR is associative.
And so I get a clause,
which is what I need.
So each one of these guys is
really equivalent to a clause.
And so I just get
a bunch of clauses.
And actually,
technically, this needs
to be three, a copy
of three things here.
It should be z4 OR z4
OR z4, which is a lot.
So check-in--
[INAUDIBLE] I realize
my check-in is broken, because
I only realized that last point
just now as I was talking.
So the actual value
that you get in terms
of-- oh, no, the number
of clauses is correct.
No, I take it back.
This is fine.
So if you understood
what I was saying,
hopefully, you can see
how big the formula
phi prime is in terms of the
number of operations in phi.
So let's see how
many people get that.
I acknowledge this may be a
little on the technical side.
OK.
I'm going to close
it, close it down.
Please enter your value.
OK.
Yeah, the correct
answer is 4k plus 1,
because each one
of these operations
is going to end up being
a row in this picture.
Each operation is going to have
a variable associated to it.
It's going to become
a row in this picture.
And so then each row is going
to have four clauses, which
define what you need--
set what you need in order
to force that variable to have
the right value corresponding
to that operation.
And so then you need-- and
you need one extra clause here
for saying that this whole
thing evaluates to true.
So that's all I
wanted to do today.
We proved those
two main theorems.
And now we know that there
are NP-complete problems.
And all of the other problems
that we can get from--
by reductions from
these problems
are also going to be NP-complete
as long as they're in NP.
So that's it.
Feel free to put some
questions into the chat,
or move on to whatever else
you're going to be doing next.
So a good question here
is, why is phi prime
not logically equivalent
with this construction?
It can't be
logically equivalent.
Logically equivalent
means that it gives you
exactly the same function.
If you set the variables
in the same way,
you get the same
result coming out.
Well, phi prime has more
variables than phi does.
So it wouldn't even
make sense to talk
about logical equivalence
because they're
two functions on different
numbers of variables.
So in that sense, it
doesn't really make sense.
What you could say is
that for every setting
of the overlapping
variables, so the variables
that appear in both
phi and phi prime--
so those are the original
variables of phi--
there's going to exist some
setting of new variables, which
is going to make the--
there's going to
be-- there will exist
some setting of the
new variables which
will make the two
formulas agree,
but that's not the definition
of logical equivalence.
So why-- going back to the
proof, the satisfiability proof
and the legal
neighborhoods, could I
go over why the number of legal
neighborhoods is polynomial.
The number of
legal neighborhoods
is not only polynomial.
It's constant.
It depends only on the machine.
It does not depend on M.
Because each cell can have
at most some fixed number of--
can have the number
of tape symbols
plus the number
of state symbols.
That depends on
the machine only.
So now we have six tape cells
for the six cells in a 2
by 3 neighborhood.
So you're going to have that
number to the sixth power.
But still, it's a constant
to the sixth power.
It's still a constant.
It doesn't depend on M.
So it's not a question
of even being polynomial.
It's a constant value.
It's a constant
multiplier if you
want to think about it in terms
of the size of the formula
that's going to result.
Don't forget we're trying
to make a formula which is--
the reduction has
to be polynomial.
It's a polynomial
time reduction.
So that means that
as n increases,
the time to calculate
the reduction increases
as a polynomial.
But we're fixing M.
So M does not change.
So therefore anything
that depends on M only
is just going to be a constant
impact on the formula.
It's not going to be--
it doesn't depend on M.
OK, everybody.
Bye bye.
See you.